pour toutes ces précisions jacques
chirac président est son dernier conseil
des ministres ce matin le chef de l'état
formulé tous ses voeux de réussite à
nicolas sarkozy il a également rendu
hommage à l'action de dominique de
villepin grâce à qui selon lui la france
est respectée en europe et dans le monde
claudine gilbert qui s'abat le vieux
chef commandant force est trompeur
plus pour longtemps c'est l'heure des
photos souvenirs à l'elysée jacques
chirac a convié les trente ministres du
dernier gouvernement de son quinquennat
pour un déjeuner d'adieu c'était ce
matin le dernier rendez-vous du
gouvernement villepin à l'élysée en 12
ans jacques chirac aura présidé plus de
6 en conseil des ministres le chef du
gouvernement lui a exprimé sa
reconnaissance
jacques chirac a permis à la france
de rentrer dans ce nouveau millénaire de
faire de la france une nation respectée
une nation écouter à travers le monde il
a permis de renforcer notre pacte
républicain et je le redis comme je les
ai dit tout à l'heure
jacques chirac qui manquera ne manquera
au monde du gouvernement et je pense
qu'il ne manquera à tous les français
nous avons offert un très beau tableau
de zao wou-ki qui me sall est à nos
grands peintres chinois et français et
qui incarne à peu les liens entre les
peuples et donc c'est un cadeau
collectif du gouvernement moment
d'émotion bien sûr alors que se tourne
une page de l'histoire du tibet la
france c'est un moment fort parce que
c'est une période bizarre j'ai créé une
autre période qui commence
et cela se sentait à la fois dans les
propos dans les attitudes et donc c'est
un moment donc on se souviendra les uns
et les autres pensent ait beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion au coût de sincérité
le président république a souhaité à
nicolas sarkozy un plein succès il lui a
adressé tous ses voeux de réussite et là
aussi la sincérité des propos de jacques
chirac a été très touchante
le président sortant et son successeur
se retrouveront demain pour la première
fois depuis l'élection lors de la
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
en attendant la passation de pouvoir
dans une semaine de rêve